former First Lady Michelle Obama is
opening up about what it was like for
her family to leave the White House
after the election of President Trump
her memoir becoming which went on sale
yesterday is already a best-seller in it
the former First Lady details her very
unlikely path from growing up in a very
small apartment in Chicago's South Side
to living at the most famous address in
the country 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
we spoke with mrs. Obama in Chicago
about her book and asked about the
current state of American politics it
seems that whatever the Obama
administration has done it seems the
current administration wants to undo how
do you handle that when you look at the
work that you all have done you know the
truth is is that the the presidencies
isn't ours to own it's the people's jobs
it's not how me and Barack feel because
we occupied that seat for eight years
and did the best that we could do and
the next president that is voted in gets
to do the same thing you know the
question that we have to ask as citizens
and as voters what direction do we want
our country to go in and we we saw here
that when you sit out sometimes you get
what you want
sometimes you don't that's the nature of
our democracy's I will faithfully
execute why do you think Donald Trump
won this election if I don't spend much
time a lot of people came to the polls
and a lot of people didn't our democracy
is clear it's just sometimes people
think my vote doesn't count and that's
just so wrong voting matters and the
people who go to the polls determine how
the country is going to be led the
notion that voting doesn't work that it
it's fixed no it's not
you know we saw in this midterms people
wanted the country to move in a
different direction and they came out in
record numbers and they voted and that's
how it works our motto is when they go
low we go high
do you still believe when they go low we
go high absolutely after all that is
absolutely you know what's the
alternative
you know because going low means you're
operating from your place of emotion you
know it doesn't necessarily mean you're
operating from a place of results more
often than not you don't get results
when you go low you just you know get
your attitude out when you're in the
white house and you have that platform
and that responsibility where every word
matters you know you're often thinking
at least Barack and I often thought is
what we're about to say gonna help is it
going to move the needle forward or is
it just going to make us feel vindicated
in the moment and you learned that
vindication in the moment is so
short-term going high doesn't mean you
don't feel have feelings and that you
don't express feelings that you don't
acknowledge hurt or pain or anger you
know that's not what going high is going
high means now you now you have the
feeling how do you express that feeling
in the world and how do you do that
responsibly you in your book with let's
let kindness in you still feel
optimistic about our country and we as a
people we as a because I lived in the
country you know I traveled the country
I saw the heart of who we are forget
race or party or ethnicity or gender
people agree with us or not people were
kind people are worried people have
issues but everybody is working for the
same thing the same goal and I got to
see that part of America hmm well she
she listened she just still remains a
class act and every everywhere I went I
was now carrying the book around because
now you can say we have it if you would
say ask her to run ask her to run and
that's the one question I didn't ask her
because I know she's sick of it and I
know it's not going to happen she said I
would live that life for eight years and
that's just not something that interest
her it's nice to hear that each of her
actions is value-based exactly you know
what I mean exactly but it's
solution-focused it's not about an
emotional make you feel better in the
moment as she said everything is
solution-focused it's how to be a leader
how to set
example and I know we're gonna hear more
of it yes interview she summed it up
well by saying the presidency doesn't
belong to them belongs to the American
people yes and well said yeah very good
answer